the movie opens up in a convenience
store in Los Angeles one Late Night with
a smalltime drug dealer named Nick
trying to decide which coffee flavor to
buy his ex-lover Dallas and his fellow
Hitman Billy Hill seem to be getting
impatient by The Dilemma so they tell
him to hurry up eventually Nick chooses
chocolate macademia flavor but to his
Misfortune the dispenser is empty he
complains to the cashier but the latter
suggests that he just choose some other
flavor neck reluctantly fills a cup with
hazelnut coffee and proce ceeds to the
counter while paying he demands for a
free cake but the cashier claims that
the free cake is available only for 20
oz coffee their discussion frustrates
Dallas who then grabs her handgun and
shoots the annoying cashier dead never
deny your customer cake not long after
they notice a police car approaching the
convenience store as a result Nick poses
as a cashier while Dallas and Billy
pretend to be the customers a police
officer walks in to grab a cup of coffee
the group manages to hide the corpse
from the officer for the the first few
moments but he soon spots Blood on the
floor with no options left they kill the
officer as well a shame they could have
bonded over their love for cake the
scene then cuts to Texas where we are
introduced to a man named Casey an old
drug dealing partner in Nick they had
parted ways several years ago and Casey
has since turned his life around he is
now married to his beautiful wife
Christine and they are looking forward
to adopting a child early one Thursday
morning Casey receives a call from Nick
who asks if can stay at his place for a
few days Casey does not seem to be
comfortable having him in his house but
he eventually agrees when Nick says that
he's getting married later while
preparing breakfast Casey tells his wife
about Nick coming to stay at their house
Christina is confused as she's never
heard Casey talk about his friend before
despite this she does not have time to
discuss it as she is getting late for
work before leaving she informs him that
she will be late that night because she
has a dinner plan with her boss she also
reminds him about an appointment with Dr
Jarvis from the adoption agency right at
8:00 Nick arrives at Casey's doorstep
and the two friends are Overjoyed to
reunite after such a long time Nick asks
about what he's been doing to which
Casey replies that he's an architect now
hearing this Nick is surprised and tells
him that he looks boring compared to how
he used to be I'm not boring you
says Casey a short while later Nick
mentions that he has some errands to run
and requests to borrow Casey's car
because his own car has a flat tire
without any hesitation Casey hands over
the car keys and Nick departs following
this Casey gets back to his work but he
is unable to focus as he is passing by
the guest room one of Nick's suitcases
grabs his attention he becomes
suspicious as it appears to be the same
one that they used while dealing drugs
after a while of deliberation Casey
finally decides to open it his
assumption turns out to be true as the
suitcase is full of heroin enraged he
calls Nick and angrily confronts him for
bringing drugs into his home Casey
orders him to pick up his stuff and
leave his house immediately however Nick
claims that he can't do that because he
has some unfinished business to take
care of Casey threatens to involve the
police and surrender the drugs to them
but Nick does not seem to be affected by
this fuming with anger Casey takes the
drugs to his kitchen and disposes of
them in the garbage unit at 11:55 Casey
hears the doorbell ring and upon
answering it he sees a pizza delivery
boy Casey asserts that he didn't order
any pizza but the delivery person
unexpectedly punches him and holds him
at gunpoint it turns out the delivery
boy is a Jamaican rosta Hitman named ice
ice asks about the drugs to which Casey
reveals that he has already disposed of
them this prompts ice to contact his
boss who orders him to eliminate Casey
after hanging up the phone ice aims the
gun at him but Casey suggests that they
smoke some ganja together before he dies
the Jamaican guy simply can't say no to
this proposition because this movie came
out in the 9s and stereotypes are
rampant so he agrees as the two smoke
ice opens up about himself he says that
he aspires to be a rapper and he's
involved in killing business just for
the sake of the money an hour passes by
during which both of them consume a lot
of weed ice then gets up and tells Casey
that it's time he is about to kill Casey
when his cell phone rings it's from one
of his friends who asks him to perform a
rap over the phone ice hesitantly agrees
and proceeds to deliver his WAP Casey
takes advantage of this distraction and
knocks ice down then ties The Hitman
with duct tape and keeps him in his
garage shortly after the doorbell rings
one more time Casey answers it to find
Dr Jarvis waiting outside in his stoned
State Casey hastily clears the remnants
of the drugs from the table and sprays
air freshener around the room before
inviting the doctor inside it turns out
that Dr Jarvis is here to interview
Casey and evaluate if he's fit to adopt
a baby Casey nervously answers the first
few questions but Dr Jarvis is
particularly curious about what Casey
did when he Liv lived in Los Angeles our
guy tries his best to cover up his past
as well as his recent encounter with ice
Midway through the interview Dallas
shows up at Casey's house believing that
Nick has left some money along with the
heroin Casey tells her that Nick isn't
home and asks her to leave but she
barges in anyway thinking that Dallas is
Casey's friend Dr Jarvis welcomes her
and requests to ask her a few questions
the latter promptly agrees and reveals
the past life of Casey she mentions that
he was a ruthless drug dealer who is not
afraid of anyone he would kill anyone
even if he liked them without a blink of
hesitation after hearing about the drug
dealing and murdering past Dr Jarvis
feels uncomfortable and wants to leave
he obviously is not going to approve
Casey for the child adoption Casey tries
his best to stop him but Dr Jarvis does
not listen and walks away as soon as he
departs Dallas holds Casey at gunpoint
and ties him up to a chair she then asks
about the money that Nick brought with
him Casey claims that he knows nothing
about it because he quit this business
many years ago here it is finally
revealed why Casey quit his criminal
life a flashback shows him and Nick in
the middle of drug dealing things didn't
work out as expected which resulted in
the shootout between the two parties
during that Casey unintentionally killed
a woman who was 8 months pregnant the
guilt overwhelmed him and since then he
decided to quit not turn himself in or
anything you know just pretend it didn't
happen Talis mocks him for his story and
intends to wait for Nick to come until
then she plans to get get intimate with
him Casey strictly refuses this claiming
that he is a married man but Dallas does
not care she undresses herself and
forces herself on Casey in the middle of
this assault Billy breaks in and shoots
her from behind splashing blood all over
Casey's face this movie goes hard just
like Dallas Billy is also here for the
money he tells Casey that Nick has
stolen $2 million from the cops and had
it hidden somewhere believing that Casey
knows where the money is Billy plans to
torture him with a saw and to blow torch
in revealing the location as he brags
about his prowess and technique of
cauterization they hear the police
sirens Billy immediately hides his tools
and goes to check in the meantime Casey
loosens the duct tape around his wrists
and grabs a frying pan before he sits
back down in the same position Billy
comes back and tells him that the police
came to raid the house next door he
again picks up his torture tools and
notices the duct tape on the floor
however before he can do anything Casey
smacks him with the frying pan several
times and until he gets knocked out
Casey then grabs a handgun and aims at
Billy's head but he remembers that he is
not the same person anymore as a result
he takes him to the garage and ties him
up inside just like ice a short while
later Nick calls Casey from a pay phone
and confides that things didn't work out
as he anticipated he apologizes to Casey
for everything and admits that he had
stolen the heroin and money from the
police Nick's breaking voice makes Casey
sense that something is wrong he asks
about the matter but Nick simply replies
that he's leaving the country and bids
goodbye as they hang up the phone it is
revealed that Nick has been shot and is
dying from blood loss following this
Casey cleans himself up as well as his
entirely messed up and blood covered
house at 5:00 a corrupt cop named kerov
arrives at the house with a bag in his
hand it turns out that kerov is the same
person from whom Nick stole the money
upon entering kerov reveals the content
inside the bag NYX severed head much
like Dallas and Billy kerov also asks
the same question about the money's
whereabouts but Casey still has the same
answer that he has no idea about it the
cop says that he believes him but he
expects Casey to know where his friend
would have hidden the money he then
presents Casey with an ultimatum if he
can find the money by 700 p.m. he will
erase all the records of the Thursday
incident basically he is blackmailing
Casey about the dead body and two of the
captives in his garage whom he is well
aware of kerov asks where he has hidden
the captives and Casey leads him to the
garage the cop takes no time in
mercilessly shooting the hanging people
to death he then tells Casey to throw
them out as it's garbage day garbage day
once the cop leaves Casey continues to
clean the house as per Cero's suggestion
he mutilates the dead bodies and
disposes of them in the trash can
outside while returning back to his
house he notices Nick's car that is
parked outside he suddenly remembers
about the flat tire that Nick was
talking about earlier Casey proceeds to
check his car and finds the money in the
spare tire in addition he also finds a
small gift box left by Nick as he was
unable to attend Casey's wedding upon
opening it he finds two watches one for
Christine and the other for himself in
the aftermath Casey takes is's phone and
calls is's boss informing him that the
heroin is set to be auctioned off at his
home at 700 p.m. thereby setting a trap
between the Jamaican gang and caser
off's corrupt cough meanwhile Casey
grabs the suitcase full of money hops
into Dallas's Lambo and heads away to
pick up his wife at 700 p.m. the
Jamaican gang and Cero's corrupt cops
meet at Casey's residence and they end
up shooting each other just as Casey had
orchestrated on the other hand Casey
meets his wife at the airport Christine
is surprised to see him there and asks
what he's doing Casey answers that he's
leaving for France and he wants her to
come with him hearing this Christine
understands that he's gotten himself
into trouble she doesn't know what to do
because she has a career here but she
also loves Casey believing that she is
not coming with him he decides to leave
alone but Christine stops him in the
nick of time and shares her decision to
accompany him she asks about the details
of the matter and Casey responds that
he'll tell her everything on the way and
thus Casey gets a happy ending that he
absolutely in no way deserves subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for for
watching